We have an awesome course planned for you.
>> We're going to facilitate learning and discussion on
different biological concepts, as well as some social issues.
>> But before we jump in, we want to take a brief moment
to mention our course expectations for you, as well as give you
a little orientation on how to interact with us here. Now first
and foremost this course is going to require a time commitment. So, be prepared.
>> But the joy of online learning means you
can take the course however you're the most confortable.
>> Hey guys.
What you want to do tonight? Oh, sure. We can do class.
>> no. I'm actually working.
>> This course is 12 lessons long. And each lesson is going to vary in the
time commitment required, and level of difficulty.
And that brings us to our second expectation:
[CROSSTALK]
Interactions.
[SOUND]
You may think that our lessons are confined to this video screen.
But in reality you can interact with us through this screen too.
>> Stopping to think and answering
questions can really facilitate future learning.
We want you to click to respond or type in a short response.
>> Now, it's important for you to remember that these interactions are
not graded. We want you to think of these as learning opportunities.
>> Now, if anything's
unclear, check out the solution video for help. Or
you can go back and re-watch videos. For example, we
might ask who are the coolest genome guides ever?
Go ahead and pick which answer you think is best.